hey everyone i welcome you all to this
junit full course by simply learn
in this complete course we will learn
everything we need to know about junit
and mokito junit
we have anuch to guide us through this
journey we shall begin with
understanding the basics of junit and
have a look at different aspects of
junit
in these aspects we shall understand the
relevance and features of junit
moving forth we shall learn the working
of junit with java and eclipse with the
help of a hands-on demo
after we have a complete knowledge about
junit and it's working
we shall go on to explore mokito in
mokito junit we shall understand what
mocking is
and how we can perform it while we are
at it we shall know about the basics of
stub and how to create it to better
understand the mokito j unit we shall
see
all these processes and the entire
working of mokito with a hands-on demo
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and don't forget to click on the bell
icon so you never miss an update from
simply learn welcome everyone to yet
another
topic on junit tutorial now in this one
we are going to talk about
what exactly is in junit uh tool all
about and how we can
do various kind of test implementations
with the help of
junit so let's talk about the agenda
which we are going to cover here
now in this one specifically we are
going to talk about like what exactly is
j unit uh what is this particular
framework all about
then we are going to talk about junit
installation how we can do the
installation of junit and what
are the different steps we can get
involved on that and then we are going
to talk about like
the features of junit what are the
different typical features of junit r
are about then j unit annotations we're
going to talk about and then
junit in java and the actual
implementations
some tutorials or some demos on how to
implement
junit with eclipse so these are some of
the main topics which we are going to
cover
all together over here as such now let's
talk about
what exactly is the junit tool all about
like what are the different things we
can implement with the help of this tool
here
so junit is basically a kind of unit
testing framework which is there for the
java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the chair unit
for the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing
now the main benefit of the junit is
like
it's using the same syntax like a java
programming language
so it makes it very easy for a java
developer to write and execute the test
cases
so most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages
so they prefer that j unit as a default
unit testing framework for them because
they get the language advantage they get
the easily integrations and the eclipse
so those benefits helps the developers
to decide junit
specifically for writing the test cases
and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code
so uh all the unit test cases will be
executed will be again executed there
every time when you run a new build so
all the unit test cases gets executed
but you also need to take care that if
you are adding up a new functionalities
you also have to add the corresponding
test cases to that
so increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time
you have to sync or you have to keep
your test cases up to date also
and as a part of every build each and
every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times
six times a day every time the all unit
test cases will be executed over there
and the response will be given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing
now unit testing refers to the testing
of these small small modules or the
small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to
have the early identification of the
defects and the bugs because
you cannot simply rely on the qa team to
perform
the testing and then provide the
feedback whereas on the
uh with the help of this unit testing
framework we can immediately get the
feedback right away once we are running
the test cases
immediately we will be able to know like
these are the different test cases which
we have
got over here now the developers don't
even have to
spend more time on fixing the bugs and
issues because
these test cases will help them with the
easy and the fast feedback
so according to that they can fix the
bugs and they can take the decision
whether the
source code is working fine as expected
or there is any kind of issues
as such present with this one so unit
test casing is something which is very
important from the developer's
perspective also
because it helps the developers to
understand that they whether they have
written a successful code
or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh increases the overall
confidence of the developers
because it increases the overall
performance and the quality of the
product also
so by having the successful executions
of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take
uh the decisions whether the source code
is ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit
which we get with the unit testing here
now of course this can be done in two
ways manual testing and automatic
testing
now in case of manual testing you have
to do this thing manually
within a manual tester or a manual
testing approach
and in this one you will not be
depending on any kind of automated tool
which can be scheduled or which can be
executed in non
interactive manner on the other hand
automatic test case is something which
uh is used to be executed using the
tool and uh it is something which is
being done
so that you will be able to get the
complete automation there is no manual
efforts which is required as such
you are going to have like complete uh
deployment and automations being done as
such in this case
so automated testing is something in
which you will be giving more focus on
the automated automation tools
you may be having one or a couple of
tools which using which you can write
the
automated test cases and you can perform
the complete automation
in case of manual testing it's quite a
you know less reliable because
you are dependent on the uh a particular
tester
which can have perform the testing
according to his efforts
and it's quite a time consuming also
because you can only run the test cases
for
probably eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is uh
quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so
so requirements so it can be done like
24 crore seven so anytime you can run
those
uh test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster as
compared to
any other manual testing approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases
really helps the developers and the qa
professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing
now let's talk about the joint
installation now as part the
of the installation of junit you don't
require to install any exe file or any
kind of program there
there are a couple of jar files which is
required which needs to be there into
the
a class path so that every time when you
write some junit test cases you should
be able to refer those jar files
because without having those jar files
into your class part of your project
you will not be able to run the change
in test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a maven build
then these dependencies will be added up
into the power.xml file
if you are referring or doing the build
from the eclipse or doing the
development from the ecrips
then you have to put up these jar files
into the class part of the project so
that these jar files can be loaded up
and dj unit can be referred over here
so the installation is pretty
straightforward but let's see like
what are the different steps we need to
follow now as a pre request of
understanding the demo about junit the
first initial two things is like
you require a jdk to be installed now
you can download the jdk8 over here from
this oracle website
and uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have
you can pretty much install it for
whatever platform is there
so for windows platform you can download
for 32 bit and the 64-bit both option
over here
and once it's installed so you should be
able to use the eclipse latest tool
now um all you need to do is that you
need to go to eclipse.org
and there you can download the latest
version of the eclipse
now these two main things which you
require because eclipse will be required
for
creating the change unit test cases and
of course how a kind of id
where you can run some test cases
changing test cases and all
and then oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for
running the jdk also and the junit uh
test cases also and eclipse here
so that's a pre-request which we got
over here in this one so
i have already got these two things
installed into my system and i have
eclipse there so let's move on to the
eclipse and see that how it going goes
on there
but before that you also require the
junit jar files because
in order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up
we require some particular files
jar files over here in this case so i
can just search for junit
4 over here and when you search for
junit 4 so what happens like
this particular page will help you or
give you all the details about the junit
4
now you can go for the version notes of
the different different versions but uh
if you want to download
all you need to do is like you can say
like download and install
and the moment you go there so it will
give you the details now there are two
jar files which is required junit dot
jar file is required over here j uh
ham crest iphone core dot jar file these
two jar files are required here
if you want to download it into the test
class path if you feel that you want to
uh a maven based project then in that
case
you have to specifically go for this
dependency into palm file
and according to that that particular
version will be downloaded and will be
referred over there
so these are the ways that how you can
get the particular softwares the
required
things into the place so i'm going to
put up this jar files into a location so
that
i should be able to get the particular
details
uh stored and i can refer to them into
my eclipse
so i'm going to download this one here
from the
maven central
so i'm going to download this jar file
and then i'm going to go back
and create hyphen code so that also i
want to download
download chart so these two jar files i
have
uh downloaded and i will be referring
these ones into my project
because these are the ones which has
been required into my project as such
so let's go back to the eclipse and uh
let's place this jar files into a
location so that
into my class what i can refer to the
complete folder with all these two java
files inside that so let's go ahead with
that
so let's create a particular new project
over here so we'll go for new
java project and here i can give it
like a simple one
a simple project name i can provide here
and
jdk i'm using like 1.8 so that's the jdk
version which i have utilized over here
and then finish
so this is the project which i have got
like in the source directory
now i'm going to create a simple uh file
over here
a new class file over here so i'll
create it like
j unit class
so i'm going to create a class over here
in this one
and of course i need to have a
particular white main also over here in
this
specific class over here because this is
the initial class i'm trying to create
over here in this one
i can create a custom particular methods
also over here but uh let's see like if
we can
execute or we can run some particular
functions as such over here
now i'm going to declare a function over
here
public void
junit
method so i'm just going to create
a method over here
i'm just going to run a particular
print statement over here
executing j unit
test cases right
now this is a kind of a method which is
there which of course i can run into my
uh public void main and this function
will be executed uh will be called upon
over here
now the thing is that uh right now uh
since it's just a normal function but
the moment i convert it like i have
uh at the rate test mentioned over here
so what will happen like this will be
converted into the form of a test cases
now of course like right now there is no
imports which is available there
as part of this one so you can see that
the uh
the the time i have added this
annotation at the rate test
i will be able to see like yes add
junit 4 library to the build path
is something which is coming up over
here or it's saying like add junit 5. so
whatever the library you feel that you
want to add you can do that
and that particular library will be
added up over here now let's go for the
junit 4 library here
the moment i do that what will happen
you will see some changes
first you will see the changes in the
top saying that import
orj dot junit dot test that's a first
import
and second import will be like junit
four you will see like these two jar
files
is automatically being picked up by the
eclipse
now even if you don't download these jar
files this is the main benefit of the
eclipse that these are already a part of
the plugins
you can see their paths that these are
already installed if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
plugins directory so the moment you use
these uh
particular methods that you want to use
the junit these will be automatically
imported over here into your system
now you can just simply call this method
into the main
void main and then the specific method
will be executed
as a form of test cases so this is the
mechanism that how you will be
setting up the project initially you got
the imports you got the
uh particular annotations configured and
with that
the uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path
whatever the java files we added up we
downloaded previously we can also
have that added up into the custom class
path we can modify this
build path of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right click
build path and configure so this jf unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can
add our external jar files also into the
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you
that how you want to perform the
customizations around that part but yes
the particular main benefit of using the
eclipse is that it's already having the
junit plugin
installed both four and five version is
installed whatever version you feel that
you want to include
it will be included and the plugins are
already installed so you don't even have
to download
the jar files manually so that's how you
will be able to do a very basic initial
setup of junit
and how a basic project can be created
over here in case of junit
in the upcoming demos we'll see like how
we can execute these
particular test cases and we'll get the
response we'll come to that point so
let's go back to the main content
right so that was the uh junior
installation demo which we saw
and we saw like how we can put up or
load the jar files relative change unit
into a class path and we can resolve the
basic uh you know features about the
chair unit about the test cases
now let's talk about some of the certain
features of the chair unit here
now there are a lot of features which we
get primary with the chair unit let's
discuss about that one by one
so the very first feature about junit is
that it's an
open source network now it's something
which is available as an open source to
you
uh we have also seen the installation so
you don't have to
really go for any kind of uh license or
something like that so you can do
any number of test cases with this
particular tool and this
uh specific automation tool here you can
automate it into jenkins no way you
require any kind of license around this
so um these can be easily integrated
these are already a part of most of the
latest eclipse installation so you don't
even have to
configure these manually because it's
already a part of your system
right second is that it provides
annotations now
main annotation we have already seen in
the previous case that when
we converted a normal function or a
normal method into the test method by
using an annotation called
at the retest so it provides a mechanism
to identify that which particular method
is a test method
and which method is a normal method
according to our classes
so these annotations really help us to
identify the methods also
and it provides us the flexibility that
these uh particular methods are not the
normal methods we need to execute you
need to uh run it in the form of test
cases so that
identification is something we will be
able to do with the help of these
annotations here uh also it provides the
excitations uh to
identify like what exactly the results
are there because
uh definitely when we are running the
test cases test cases we need to assert
that
what should be the value so using the
assert uh
you know we can accelerations we can
actually compare that okay
this method is giving this value suppose
there is an addition
uh method which is available there which
is giving like
a plus b is equal to c so c is like 5
plus 15 is
20. so with the help of asset i'm saying
like uh whatever the response i'm going
to get from the function
when i give the values a and b as 5 and
15 so that should be 20 value
so in the asset i can hard code like
okay this is the value this is the
response which i should be getting
and once the function is executed i
should be able to get this particular
output as in 20 over here
so that comparison when you do you will
be able to understand
easily that yes when we are doing the
asset i am getting the proper response i
am getting the proper output over here
so assertion is something which is very
important to compare the things to
compare the inputs which we are getting
from the application source code
next it provides the uh test runner so
we can basically
run the test runners over here to
execute the test cases so
you can configure this within the
pipelines you can configure it with
eclipse and
various automations during the build
automations also you can configure it
so that flexibility you will be able to
get with these test runners here
and it also allows you provide a better
feedback channel because
it acts like a very good feedback
provider because the moment you are done
with the development
you will be able to get an instant
feedback so the overall quality of the
code is
going to be increased in this case and
that's definitely helpful for you
because
with this uh approach with this junit uh
framework
you will be able to get a quite faster
and a perfect
uh code writing tool or a quality tool
which is available there so
definitely the overall quality of the
code is going to improve
with the help of this junit framework
and
it provides the automations also because
these unit uh
test cases are having the flexibility
that you can configure it within the
pipelines
you can automate it with the help of
this framework that you can completely
help
or you can have a complete automated
workflow with the help of this
particular framework and it provides you
an instant feedback the feedback channel
is quite instant in case of this j unit
now let's talk about the junit
annotations we have already seen like
the main benefit of the annotation is to
define uh to provide the metadata about
the methods to the different ones
so annotations also refer to the
synthetical uh method data
added to the java source code so having
a particular better
of feasibility and identification is
also quite easy
so also the overall structure of the
source code can be done in a better way
and the readability is also good when we
talk about the annotations here
the biggest main difference between the
uh j unit and dj unit 3 was the in
the introduction of the junit
annotations
so uh earlier before j2 unit 3 we were
not able to identify like if
this is in kind of a test method or this
is a kind of a source method over here
so that identifications is quite easy
after the involvement or the
introduction of the
junit 4 framework over here
also like this is something which is
really helpful to us to see like how
exactly we can overall uh read the
overall source code because you have so
many so many source code there
present to your project so annotation
should be able to
uh you know help you to identify the
that these are the
main portions with these are the
components which is part of the unit
test cases not the actual source code
so at the rate test is something which
is um uh you know going to tell us that
uh the
the specific method with the public void
uh declaration
can be a run or can be executed as a
test cases this is not a simple method
this is not an application source code
method this is a test method over here
now at the date before is something
which is uh used to
run some statement before each and every
test case is executes
maybe having some additional or initial
connectivity is something you can do
with the help of
add that it before at the rate after is
something which you can do after the
execution of the test cases like
some statements which you want to
execute after the uh test cases so
that's something you can
do or you can go with the help of at the
date after
and after it ignores something which you
can configure if you feel like during
the
test execution you feel to ignore some
statement so that's the way
you can use the ad that it ignores there
so add that it ignores add the date
after
add that it before and at the rate test
these are the four
annotations which is being used most of
the time into your
junit test cases right let's talk about
some bit more
now after it before is something which
is being used to execute the classes
uh some statement before even you know
any kind of test class executes
so not only uh you know before executing
any method this is something before
even loading up any kind of uh test
classes so before at the at the rate
before class is being used
similarly at the rate after will be
there to execute it after all the test
classes
and uh if we have a timeout configured
so what will have that
we will be able to set up a timeout
while executing the test cases so
timeout value can be configured over
here and then
uh if you feel like if you want to
handle some exceptions
during the test execution so that's
where we can use this custom
annotations over here to have the
exceptions handled or configured over
here in this one
so these are some of the very important
annotations which is available there on
the chair unit perspective
now let's talk about some another demo
on chair unit testing in the java like
how we can
pretty much configure the test cases in
junit for a programming language called
java
and how we can get along or get execute
those things so now we are going to see
like how
exactly we can you know go for the uh
execution of some java files onto our
command line and how we can
using the command line run some
execution of the test cases
typically we do it from the eclipse but
uh from the command line also we are
going to see like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so i'm going
to open this
uh particular java file over here so to
get a better understanding here
so i'm going to use the oj.unit junit uh
class over here in this case so we are
having a couple of imports
these are the standard imports so you
can do like orj.jstar also if you don't
want to go for the specific
imports here now here we are going to
create a test unit as an uh
sample class and in this one we got the
void main over here which is the main
portion of any kind of class here
the only thing which we got over here is
that we have created a test
method over here called test print
message
so we are assigning a value called
message a variable over here as and
simply learn
now what happens like uh we will be able
to uh like you know do the assert equals
over here
that if the value of message is like
simply learn
so it will be able to help us with the
proper
output and there will be no errors as
such over here
so everything will be smooth and that's
what we are trying to execute over here
in this case
and we are running into the null void
that these are the test cases we want to
run or we want to execute over here
now all we need to do is we need to
compile this one we
really need to compile this scale uh
test cases over here this file
and then we have to run that one so for
that let me open the command prompt
so now in this case we will be using the
java c command prompt here
and we will be copying the j unit into
the uh class path so that
we will not be able to get any kind of
uh class not found issues over here
so test unit junit.java we are going to
run
so if there is no exceptions as such we
will be able to get
no errors here now i'm going to run the
particular class file with the help of
java command because java c is to
convert the dot java file to the dot
class file the compile format and then
in order to run the dot class file we
have to go for the
java command line here now this means
that uh there is
no issues as such with the test cases
and everything is working fine as
expected over here in this one
so the assert equals is going to help
you to identify that if
the execution is proper and let's say
like if we put up some content like
some different content over here in this
asset equals
so i'm going to again execute this one
so that i will be able to see like if
you know what will happen that if this
message value and this value does not
matches like in normal situations it
will say like okay
uh the particular uh you know output is
going up and
there is no errors as such right so
let's see like what exactly
uh it will happen that if we go for the
executions like if we
save this file in such a way that we are
providing some wrong
inputs and what will happen to our asset
equal over here
so i'm going to again compile the file
here so again a new class file will be
available
and this time i'm going to execute this
class file again over here in this case
and the moment you did it the asset will
give you the uh
comparison over here saying that there
is a failure of the comparison
why there is a failure of the comparison
because according to the code base
it was expecting the value called simply
learn
but it simply got the value called
simply learn one two which means that
your test cases over here got failed
down
so this is the real way that how you
will be providing the comparison
like what you should be putting up to
the application and what kind of
response you should be getting in in
return of that so that's
where you will be able to provide a
proper and a complete
comparison here which will help you to
understand that what exactly output
you're going to get over here
and that's where the output will be
completely
available to you and you will be able to
get a proper output as such here
right so this is the way that how the
comparison will be performed and how you
will be able to see like these two
comparison being done here as such
so this is the way that how you're going
to run the test cases
in the form of the uh from the command
line here
so let's go back to the main document
right
now the next one which we got over here
is the changing test cases using the
eclipse because from the command line we
saw like using the comma line we can do
but we got like so many test cases which
is available there so it's not easy for
us to run those one by one
so we will be doing it through the
eclipse so that we can see like how the
execution can be really done
and we can get a hold of those
particular components so let's go back
to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here
now let's create a new project again
here
j unit
project right and uh finish
so a new j project a junit project will
be created
now in this one you can see like there
is no executables libraries for junit
but you can include it now also but i'm
going to do it later on so i'll go for
the
j unit project class
right so this is a kind of a test class
here so i'm not going to put the
null the public void mean over here in
this one so
finish now in this case what i'm going
to do is like i'm going to
you know replace this content over here
so uh with this uh particular ones
and uh going to have some basic core
base added up over here
so i'm going to import some particular
junit
uh libraries over here so over here like
oj.j unit i'm going to import these ones
and i got like this
class over here junit uh you know
project so i just have to rename it a
little bit so that it can be the
name of the actual class uh name here so
that's fine
so everything is fine but the only thing
is that we are getting some failures and
problems over here because it's not able
to identify these
specific junit related executables like
the functions and the methods
for this one again the previous like
previous case you have to do the
uh particular addition of the library to
the build path
so that you will be able to have like
these automatically resolved over here
in this one
right so you can see now that the unit 4
started reflecting over here in this
case and you did not got any kind of
errors now over here in this one so you
can simply save this
and now you can you are good to go for
running the executions over here
so you can simply say like right click
over here
run s and change unit test and when you
do that
on the left hand side you will be able
to get a little bit different viewpoint
over here
which says like yes test unless code j
unit is something which is executed
perfectly fine
if for any reason let's say like i
change the value of
string 1 here as in string 1 just an
typo error i'm trying to do here so that
i can show you that how the test cases
really fails
so assert equals is basically helping to
find out that if
the comparison between the two
attributes is correct
that means that uh you know the inputs
which we are putting up and whatever the
output we are getting
it's both the same here when you do that
you will say like there isn't
failure over here to the test cases now
i'm seeing the
failure trace over here so i'll just
move this one to the console view
so it says like it should be like string
but i got like string one over here
which is causing the problem
here because of the type of error which
i did the whole execution of the test
cases got failed
so i'm just going to revert my changes
back here and again run the test cases
it will all be okay right now again over
here so that's a main reason that how
the execution really happens in the
overall
mechanism and the system can be
implemented over here in this case
so that's how we basically go on and we
execute some
junit test cases here now in this one we
are going to talk about like how exactly
we can use
both marketer and junit here to go for
the unit testing
but before even talking about these two
tools here let's focus on to
understand like what is exactly a unit
testing here
now there are various kind of testing
which is actually available into our
particular industry
and into our software testing world
there but yes
there is a very important scope and a
position
of the unit testing here so unit testing
is something which uh we also call is an
kind of a component uh testing
is actually a software testing technique
in which
single component of a software is being
tested
we are not talking about like how
exactly our application is going to
interact with other applications and
it's going to interact with
uh it's not a complete full-fledged
application testing
so in this case what we are looking
forward is like it
this is something in which we are
focusing on how exactly
we can only validate and test out a
single component a single component is
what
we are basically talking about over here
right and uh when we say like how
exactly uh we want to perform we want to
achieve the setup here
so this is the main mechanism or this is
the main kind of testing which
an individual developer performs at its
own end
to see like whatever the piece of source
code he's writing whether it's working
fine
as expected or not so this is where
we are able to see like uh the
exactly what we are trying to achieve
here and
how a full-fledged or a basic testing
validation can be done
now the main objective of this unit
testing is to
pick a unit a very basic small small
unit of
the source code to verify it so that
it will be uh the moment the developer
develops the code base at that moment of
time only this thing will be validated
and will be fixed on so this is
something which we are looking forward
over here
to achieve like how the automation needs
to be done and needs to be achieved over
here in this case
next thing is what exactly is the
marking here now we talked about like j
unit here but next one is like what
exactly we are talking about
as in a particular marking over here now
when we talk about mocking so
we are basically uh trying to understand
like what exactly
uh we are performing for what purpose we
are going for the mocking process here
so mocking refers to the development of
objects
which are mock or clone of real objects
they are not the exact uh objects or we
can say like that's not the exact
scenario which we are going to implement
but it's kind of a duplicate or it's
kind of a temporary marks which we are
creating
so that we will be able to get it
implemented so
mocking is something which is kind of a
reference or a kind of a clone of
an existing or a real object here
so in this technique what happens that
the mock objects are being used
instead of the actual real object so
it's not like we are directly
or we are going to access the exact real
objects over here
so we are talking about like uh using or
going through the
uh specific mock objects over here in
this one so that's where we are putting
up the
main focus right and mock objects
actually give a particular output uh
for each and every input whatever the
inputs you pro you are going to provide
you are going to get any particular
desired output so
the marking is going to process all
these inputs
give you the desired output and to
understand like how the
implementations and the setups can be
done right
so for this kind of mocking process
mocking a framework
is something which is quite popular so
marketer is one of the framework which
is available there
which uh is desired for this kind of uh
work or this kind of approach only
where we are trying to see like how we
are we want to perform a mocking
implementation over here right so let's
talk about the marketer tool because
that's a primary tool which is there for
the
mocking activity and we have already
focused on like marketing is and process
in which
we are uh trying to uh process uh the
mock objects rather than the real
objects so that's kind of
uh verification here so marketo is a
kind of a job-based framework which is
being used for
doing the unit testing on the job
application so
if you have written the source code in
java programming language then marketer
is a kind of a framework for you
so this is something which is helpful
for validating the development of the
um kind of application source code here
so you will be able to validate it how
your application is going to behave
and it's going to work so when we talk
about market market over here so
it basically gives you a variety of
information like what exactly approach
you are looking forward
and what is the end result you are
trying to establish over here
so that's the main focus of the market
oh which we are going to get
and it's for the basic uh approach over
here
so java reflection api is basically used
uh internally to generate the mark
objects that's a
core component you can say like the
backbone of this whole uh
mocking approach over here mokito is
used to
simplify the test development by marking
the external dependencies
and using them in the source code so
it's kind of a
blending in the whole environment there
so that your application is going to get
the desired
environment and uh being in that
environment it can
start processing the inputs and then
give the desired output accordingly
so this is what we are trying to uh you
know implement as such over here to see
like how exactly this
mocking can be done and makito can
really help us in this approach here
right now what are the different
pre-requests which we require to learn
more
so we basically need two important p
request over here
first of all we need the hands-on
experience in java programming language
so
java programming language is very
important because mokito is something
which we can write in the java
programming language it uses the
java programming language syntax so
that's a very important thing there to
be considered
and second one is the junit framework
implementation so these two things we
basically require
for performing a complete full-fledged
marketer approach or mocking
testing over here so these are the two
important uh components or you can say
like
the two core prerequisites which we need
to process before going for the
mokito implementation right so let's go
to see understand like how mokito
framework can be configured in eclipse
because
eclipse is the prime tool for creating
the uh development source code for the
java programming language
so we need to see like how we can
configure the emojito framework over
there because that's the one
that's the single ide which will be
utilized by the developers there so
let's go ahead in that in this demo we
are going to talk about like how
we can create a simple uh junit and
mokito related
uh program over here so that we can have
a basic project created
and we can also have some basic program
created on that part so
let me open the eclipse here now in this
one what i'm going to do is like first
of all i'm going to
create a maven project once my maven
project is created then i'm going to
include
market to nj unit related dependencies
and after that
i'm going to write a very small source
code just to see like
how exactly our dependencies are getting
dissolved and
my source code which will come up as an
error earlier will come up as unhealthy
over there
so all i have to do is i have to just
right click over here
new and here i need to go for project
like i want to go for a particular
maven project here so i can expand the
maven over here
and go for maven project here it will
basically ask me certain values
uh i want to use the default workspace
location
so i'll just say next um then i want to
have it uh like i want to go ahead with
this overall process so these are all
projects
like what exactly uh you know archetype
you architecture type you want to go so
i can just go for the default whatever
is selected i can just go with that
and here i will be providing like what
is a group id so i can provide a group
id called com.simplylearn or depending
on your organization you can actually
provide it
so here i can provide makito and the
version will be like this and
this is the same way like how the
project will also be created the package
will be created in case of
the project here so then i'll just say
finish
and uh on the left left-hand side i will
be able to see like my
uh specific source code which is
available there so this is something
which
is uh going to come up over here so it's
actually trying to uh resolve some of
the
particular options like some of the uh
you know like uh the components like
test executions
those are required over here so i'll
just uh
go for this particular reservation later
on
right so i'll just open this palm.xml
file here
and this is the bom xml file right so
it's basically
looking forward for certain changes like
this jar file so this jar file is not
actually available over here so once i
ran the build and
you know those kind of setup can be done
then it will be able to download
those particular dependencies so if you
right click on this one you will be able
to
see that a particular maven build option
here so
i can just run the movement build or you
can just run the movement clean here
so according to that the maven will be
uh downloading certain plugins and it's
just trying to do some
uh particular process over here so on
the left hand side
the source main test
the same package which is available
there the same packages is coming up
there so
app test is available there so here the
test
is being available here i can see like
some couple of
junit related test cases is already
being there like i created a kind of a
sample project so
in here a basic java and a basic uh
class file or a test suite is already
being available here
so all i have to do is like i have to
just try to see like if i can go ahead
with this uh executions there
now it's using like junit uh 3.8.1 over
here so i can definitely go for a
version
which is uh higher like around junit
four or five there but let me try to do
a clean build over here may even build
over here so
uh to see like if it really works on
there so
uh what have the goals i need to do i
need to go for the goals called clean
install so that's a goal which we need
to do here
so uh mvn will automatically be resolved
there but
clean install is the goal which i want
to look forward over here
so let's see like what it really happens
so it's going to download some couple of
plugins whatever the plugins i'm trying
to provide here
some dependent plugins will be
downloading so all that stuff will be
downloaded
this is the first time we are running
there so that's why it made download
some little bit
more uh jar files than expected ones
not you must have seen like these are
all jar files is not like something we
are using into our project
but these are kind of for jar files
which is being used by the plugins
by the maven itself so for that purpose
it's actually going to that particular
level
but once these are cached up there next
time if you do the run
if you do any kind of burst there you
are not going to see all these
entries so let me rerun the build here
to show you like how clean the output
would be there
so i can just go for clean install again
and say run
and this time the output which will be a
little bit less there so
in this case as you can see if i expand
the output
so here first of all it ran like it
performed the clean activity
then it compiled my source code here it
also compiled my test cases here in this
one
then my test cases got executed over
here so you can see like
it's something which got xx uh
executable over here so this is the test
which is available
i can click on that and i can see that
and after that uh
it went on and prepared the final
artifact here
which also means like it performs both
the compilation and the test cases
execution
and this is what we are doing in any
kind of movement project
and on top of that i'm using a j-unit
related frameworks
so this is a mechanism where we can have
some dependencies like i can go for
j-unit here
i can increase the dependencies i can
try out the pair so all that stuff i can
do here
right and one more dependency which i
can include is of the
marketo here so i can uh include
the marketo related dependency also over
here
so that uh we can see like how exactly
the response is coming up there
so you can see like it's uh you know
when i go for the resolution over here
like clean build
clean install so i can just go ahead
with this
so this time it's actually going for the
mokito one so
you can see like all the steps has been
executed
and we have got the end result so the
build is successful
and i have got the test cases also so
this is the test file where i'm actually
loading up some junit related uh
executables there so i can just go with
that and
uh whatever the activity assert we are
using over here
so uh using which we can do the
comparison so this is a way like how
a basic project can be created in maven
and on top of that how we can manage the
dependencies for mokito
and for change unit here right so that
was a demo
in which we talked about like how
exactly we can configure mokito into our
eclipse here
now let's see like when exactly we uh
require the marketer to be implemented
now in this case what happens like uh
when when exactly you feel like you need
to have a mokito implementation
or how we can go for the uh
implementation altogether here
so for example when a component is to be
tested or a single unit needs to be
tested
so this unit or component actually
depends on some other component
which is uh kind of in in development
process or maybe some other developer
owns that component and you are not
exactly
validating that component you are
violating your own component
but since it's actually dependent on
other component or some other
unit of the of the whole application so
that's the reason why you may not be
going you may not be able to perform the
end-to-end
testing but yes with the help of mokito
you will be able to get the mock objects
so that you can perform the testing
there you don't have to held up
with that other component dependency you
can resolve all these dependencies like
that
and you can just proceed further with
your verification
and your implementation so this is the
main benefit which you get when you talk
about the marketer so that you can get
see that a full-fledged understanding
like how exactly these different
components are going to be processed
here
right and uh when there is any kind of
concern like
uh if if uh you know like if you feel
like there are some infrastructure
components which is making the testing
impossible
so in that case also we can use the
marketer to mark some infrastructure
components
so that we can proceed further with the
validation and the testing here
so all the hindrances and all the
problems which we normally face when we
talk about the implementation
all those things can be really
implemented with the help of mokito here
so that's a main benefit
which you get over here in this one now
let's talk about the next concept so the
next concept which we have is
what exactly is a stub very important
concept here so
stub is a kind of object which
holds up a predefined information a
predefined data we cannot do a kind of a
dynamic
verification in case of unit testing
because we have to
uh limit the scope of testing we are
putting up some inputs over here
just to see like how our application is
going to behave
these predefined data will act like a
inputs and
the test cases are going to process
these inputs and give us the desired
output so these outputs we will be then
analyzing to understand that how our
application is going to behave
or in other terms like how application
is reacting to these inputs
so that we can get an end-to-end desired
output as such here
also it can be referred to as an object
that looks like
exactly a carbon copy of a real object
of course it's not a real object it's a
kind of
uh mock object over here in this one but
it will give you the exact different
details or you can say like things that
output as such over here in this one
so that's a main benefit which we get
with the stuff that it helps us to get a
mock object instead of the real object
so that we can get ahead with the
testing and we can get all our
environment
for our test executions there
right and stubs actually uh they can
actually return
the specific uh output here like
whatever the
output you require so that will be
returned over here whatever the inputs
you provide that
is going to be processed by this one and
the desired output will be provided
to you over here in this one now these
stuffs are used to
reduce the complexities right so that
occur while uh creating the real object
so
that's also the complexity which is
going to be reduced
when we talked about the uh these
specific stubs as such here
so whenever we talk about these tabs we
talk about the implementation so this is
where the
complexities get reduced when we talk
about the
replication or the marking of the real
objects here
right so let's talk about like how we
can see the
stub in real action so that we can get a
better understanding because from there
we will be able to know like what is the
mean importance of stub in the whole
mocking approach here so let's go ahead
with that in this demo we are going to
talk about
like how we can create some pre-request
for testing out a stub here
so i'm going to create a required maven
project and a
couple of class files over here to make
a kind of
environment so that we can test it out
the stub implementation in mokito
so first what i need to do is like uh i
need to just go ahead with the maven
project
so movement project is what i need to
create a very basic project i want to
create over here
you don't have to do much of the changes
like not uh much
things you need to talk about over here
so uh
the package direction i can make it like
okay i just want the uh particular
package
if uh if you don't want to have the
package and you would want to directly
store the source code in
source means java and you want to put
the class directly over there
without having any kind of uh particular
comm and all that stuff so you can do
that also over here in this case so that
will be much faster so you then you can
just go for the finish here
and you will be able to see like a
project created
like a source main java then uh this
particular
package name is there and source uh test
java is also there so here is the test
file here is the main file
i i can go ahead with this one i can
create a file over here
uh you can pretty much do that stuff
also so uh or you can change like
this existing one also so what i'm going
to do is like i'm going to create a new
class file here so i'm going to say like
okay create new class file
and in this one i'm going to put the
particular
class name and a specific content so uh
let's
see like how exactly we can go so we can
go for a particular
uh class creations as a chair or we want
to
create so one class and one interface we
want to create so that we will be
creating over here
so i'm going to create a interface here
right so
to do service
so that's the interface name which i'm
trying to provide here
and uh in this one
i'm just pasting the content
so this is already configured here so
i just have to configure like this right
so uh then i'm just going to resolve
this one so the
java.util.list is also resolved so this
is the to do service.java which is
available there
now what i have to do is like i i'm just
trying to create it over here
and i'm just uh trying to create an
another class file over here in this one
so which is like my to do business impl
over here which will be using this
interface right so i'm going to
create
a particular class file in this one
and we are going to create it
okay great so in this one again i'm
going to paste this content so
i have to just sync
this one so this is what so i have to
just rename it a little bit
of this one so i have to just
rename as in particular this as
over here great so now
i'm pretty much done here so whatever
the inputs are required
i can actually go it just this delta i
want to remove it
and uh here we go so we are creating a
particular to do
service uh mechanism over here in this
one so
we are also talking about the
uh list here so this list where i can
go for the auto resolution here so i'm
just going to save it
and uh then i'm going to see like for to
do
here so to do is something which is
coming up as a
particular uh service here so a little
bit
changes in this uh interface also so
i can just you just have to sync it on
the names
so uh whatever name you are following
you are using so that you need to
change over here in this case so here
also in tutorial service i have got it
renamed
so that's where it got successfully
resolved and
as far as the error list is confirmed so
i can just import that also
so i'm just done here so if you by
chance change
this class name then you change the java
file name also calling there
so that you will be there in proper sync
up over here
so that's uh something which is
available there which we can use to see
like how the implementation can be done
and that's a basic output which you're
getting over here now this is where we
have got all the required source code
available there when we will be testing
out the stub
so at that time we can actually use
these one interface and one class over
here
so this class is basically going for the
interface call over here in this one and
that's how it's going on
the implementation so we'll come back
during the testing during the
verification of this stuff
at that moment of time this will act as
a kind of basis for
us here so this is a kind of basic
structure that how you create a basic
uh program or a basic source code over
here in this one so what i'm going to do
is like i'm going to just create
these stubs over here in this one to
test it out violated that the
things there so last time we created the
java source codes here now the steps we
will be creating
over here in this one then we are just
trying to
create first one is for the to do
service
so to do service
stop so that's the name which i'm going
to use and just finish it off
and uh i'm just going to put the content
over here
so just in order to try out the
particular matching over here in this
one
so to do stub is what we are trying to
implement so that's what we are going to
see here so i'm just going to remove
this mechanism so i'm able to see like
all the imports is working fine
in this case we are just trying to put
some a dummy information so you can see
like this is the array this is the error
list content which we are trying to
provide over here in this stuff
so uh we are basically trying to
understand like how in the mocking
activity
we are trying to mark some particular
inputs here so that
my stubs will be able to pick those up
and they will be able to return those
there
so that's what we are trying to do here
now as far as this uh
stub is configured this is done so we
have to
go for an another step here which will
be there for the to do business impl
so we have to create uh this one for uh
that
particular implementation so we
have to put the content over here in
this one to do to put the two
uh do business impl stop here right so
i'm going to paste the content here
just to uh just to match up the things
so i have to
uh just put this content here so i have
to just rename this one
because uh even if we create some files
sometimes
we may have to rename it so that keeping
in mind i can just put this one here
and say okay and uh i'm just going to
remove this
component here and here we go so we have
got like
uh these components like this is
something which is available there
we have got uh the implementations which
we are trying to do
we have got to do service and to do
service stuff both here
but i can these are the kind of wrong
interfaces
so idly my interfaces is com dot
simply learn dot stub
so that's where we have got the
particular to-do service over there and
similarly here also we have got the
particular ones which is available so
which is also there in the
specific
com.simplylearn.stop.todoservicestub
service
here so this is a mechanism where we
will be able to find out
even if i don't give this import that's
totally fine because i'm already there
in that package so i can just refer it
from there
and we also have the junit related ones
which is available there so we are
getting the
errors for the j-unit uh components over
here in this case
so we also have the pom.xml file here in
which my junit is being utilized
so uh you know in this one we are
basically trying to use
some references around the j unit here
so you can get it
on board on that case so i can just try
to run on the
particular movement build here to see
like if all the dependencies are getting
implemented
so that we will be able to
download some required dependencies so
clean install
again i'm going to just refer it over
here i can just uh run the
specific test also like if i feel but
i'm just trying to download some couple
of
uh components over here in this case so
if there is any kind of issues which
you're getting during the execution so
you will be able to see over here
for instance like oij.junit does not
exist over there
right so uh since these packages are not
downloaded or not installed so that's
why you're getting the issues
as such over here in this case right
so these are the uh references which is
available there i can just
go ahead and import some of the
junit related ones in this case
if i feel like i want to run it so i can
run this java file also over here this
file also i can run it over here
right so those are different options
which is available which we can utilize
in this case
so i'm just adding the junit 4 library
so that my uh all references related to
junit should be resolved here
and the moment i picked up that one you
can see like all the
errors related to j unit is gone now i
can run my build here
to see like if it's getting successful
so uh this time
okay so uh it's it's going for that
particular mechanism so
i can change the specific
uh version as in 4.0 let's see like
it's getting resolved so it should be
able to download that
particular artifact so i just have to
find out that what is the version what
is the latest version we want to provide
and according to that the artifacts will
be there and it will be executed
so uh there are some cases when we are
using uh
the default mechanism of creating a
junit or um even project in
eclipse sometimes it actually uses an
older version so it was using 3.8.1
version
which is old version so i'm using 4.0 so
this source code is actually prepared
according to 4.0
and the moment i started using that the
moment i tried on that one there
so you can see like here it got executed
like both the test cases got executed
over here i have got the response over
here in this one like these two test
cases
is being provided over here so test run
is two there is no failure
all good and then ultimately it went on
to the jar file preparation here
so this is a way like how the stub is
actually going to uh particular
uh you know it's going to call the
particular specific classes but yes
in this case we are just trying to input
some values some
static values which is not the real
objects but it's kind of a mock
often a real object and that's how we
are going to continue with our test
cases
just to see like you know some inputs if
they are not there we can still
go for the testing and we can do the
verification here
so this is a mechanism like how we can
test out a stub
to go to see like to understand like how
the overall mocking is going to happen
here
so that was the main uh implementation
on how this a
stub can be implemented in the whole
process to see like how exactly we can
go ahead with them
now the next demo which we are going to
talk about is like how we can
full fledge implement the complete
marketer code here
so that the end-to-end implementation of
the marking of real objects
is what we can get over here in this one
so this will give us the complete
insight about this
whole process now first we will be
creating a specific
uh we are taking up a stock inventory
kind of example over here
so we are going to create a java file
over here which is named as
stock.java so i'm just going to create a
class file here
called stock
and in that case we will be providing
the content here
so i'm going to create a stock class
which is having
certain methods certain functions stock
is the main function which is available
there
now we have to create a particular
interface which is going to
uh you which is going to be used to get
the stock there
and uh then ultimately at last we will
be getting a one test file which will be
testing out this thing the communication
and see like if the marketer is getting
passed or the test case is getting
passed or not
so this is the class file which is
available there get stock id
set stock id so basic getter and setters
are being used
as used over here in this case so now i
have to create a particular interface
here
with the name called stock service
and in this case i have to
call the get
price over there so get price is
basically configured over here in this
one
right so we are going to just call upon
on that to see like how exactly it goes
out there
right so we will be utilizing this one
so this is the
interface which is calling up the class
called stock.java
now once the stock main class in stock
service or stock interface has been
created
now we have to create a particular
portfolio class here
this portfolio is a kind of interface
which is going to
uh consume this uh specific stock here
so portfolio
uh class is what we are going to create
here so i'm just going to use it
and
it's using some list operations so i'm
going to just import the java.util also
so that these can be imported so these
are some couple of uh
activities like under this one we are
also calling up these
uh stock service interface so that that
can be calling up the stock internally
and uh this is kind of a business logic
which is happening so
portfolio.java is kind of a business
logic business layer where i'm just
trying to call them the main class there
to fetch the details
through an interface and in this one we
are basically doing the
all uh processing like whatever the
activities i'm trying to do
so here i'm doing the processing about
the data here right
so this is what we have from the source
code perspective now we will be moving
on to the test cases perspective where
we will be
writing a test file to do the mocking
over here
and to get the stocks and uh try to do
some verification
so now i'm going to create a particular
portfolio tester here
which will be testing this
specific uh portfolio here so that's
what we are going to do
right so it's going to use some of the
mokito related uh
jar files here and since we already have
those uh dependencies like the we
already got those
added up to our palm.xml file so and
these are also being shown up as an
maven dependency here so both 4.0 and
this market to dependency is there in
the maven dependencies
and that's why we are not getting any
errors for these imports here
and we are getting some list related
errors so let me import those also
and we should be fine by now here so as
you can see like here
we are when we are doing the
verification right
so using this portfolio tester we are
actually inducing
some stacks so here you can see like we
are doing some setup
we are calling that stock service over
here so that we will be able to call
upon or we will be able to get the
information and here we are actually
putting up some content
so the whole idea why we are putting up
this content just to
uh have the implementation we are just
trying to
replicate uh real objects here uh these
are not the actual real uh
configurations or real information which
we are getting from the
uh end users but these are the the dummy
informations or the dummy data which we
are trying to provide here
and depending on that we will be able to
get like
how it's going on there so we are
basically trying to
call a function called tester.setup
there tester.setup is what we are trying
to
uh call upon over here which will set up
the initial information
and then we are calling the test market
value so my test market value will
basically give me
a a pass or fail kind of uh
result set here so that depending on
that i can decide that whether it's
successful or not
and this test market value only here we
are putting up some dummy informations
and against these dummy informations the
test cases will be executed
so let's just run it uh my build is
already success so i don't have to run
it again there
so what i need to do is like i need to
go for this portfolio tester
dot java here so that i will be able to
get the results
and here we go we are getting the pass
output over here in this one right
so this is what we are trying to do just
to see like how the implementation
should be done there
i can go for a negative scenario like
where i can just a little bit
modify uh something over here in the
output
and uh i'm just trying to change a
little bit of
uh specific uh output so that's what i'm
trying to do here so
um i can definitely go and see like if
this is something going to
uh process properly or is there any kind
of problem which we are getting over
here
i can also remove this decimal value
just to see like if uh
i'm getting successful over here or not
so i'm just running the
test cases again and here we go we got
the response as in failure
because uh the expected thing is not
coming up like whatever we are returning
so that's where the failed uh it's going
down for the failure
i'm going to roll back my things here
and see like if it's again getting
success or not
so yes here we go we got the pass
success over here the past status over
here in this one
so just like that you can actually mock
the objects you can put some inputs and
according to that the responses will be
coming up there
and you can go ahead with that
particular mechanism so this is the way
that how
the things really gets moved on when we
talk about the
marketo and how we can mark the real
objects and we can
test out our application here so that's
what we
do with the market okay so that was a
complete uh
marketer code or you can see like a
complete demo over here like how the
overall process really gets implemented
over here in this one
right now what are the different
benefits of mokito let's process that
one by one so
the main benefits of mokito is like
first of all we'll get started with the
very first one
is like the no handwriting
so that's a very first benefit which is
coming up over here
now second one is the object creation
third one is the safe refactoring
then we have an exception support uh
benefit which we get over here
then we have got like the annotation
support which is available there
and then the order support so these are
some couple of benefits which we got
over here
to completely understand like how
exactly the
uh particular mokito can be really
achieved over here in this one right
so this is the real benefits of marketer
here that brings us to the end of this
video
i hope this was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
regarding this video
please feel free to drop them in the
comment section below we will be happy
to help you thank you stay safe and keep
learning